hey guys uh we just watched uh the first
episode of loki just pulled up my phone
here really quick to
give you guys our instant thoughts on it
i know like
we're not hopping here to go whoa wow
oh my god uh this one hit me on a deeper
level just being like so wowed by it
it's everything i wanted it to be and
more
like easily it gave me literally
everything i wanted it to be
more the only social media embargoes of
lyft so really can't say much
there's a phenomenal scene work between
tom hiddleston and owen wilson that does
such a successful job of doing like an
introduction to this new world with the
tva
reintroducing loki introducing new
characters setting up your series but
also keeping it
character driven while also getting
existential and philosophical
uh and and having these really
interesting sci-fi
thematic explorations like it commits to
all these things while also being
so visually cool with
amazing fantasy sci-fi music
john please oh no yeah saying everything
everything you've been saying is true no
this is exactly what i was hoping for
and then a little bit more it really
sweeps you up and it really feels like
you are being witness to you know sort
of an
awe-inspiring but also very foreboding
expansion to the universe with this you
know new
scope that they're introducing us to and
yeah it manages to have all that
on wonder but in a very sort of twilight
zone-esque kind of package
retro but also timeless in a way very
obviously futuristic in sci-fi as well
and yeah i loved at least as of this
first episode the way they reintroduced
loki
the way they sort of touch upon just you
know
the things that we're all aware of and
uh i can't wait to see what they grow
out of this because yeah it seems like
the potential is
so broad and it's all kind of yeah tied
together by some wonderful performances
everything i thought was was really
beautifully hewn and rendered uh
even just to you know the construction
of
the literal world of the tva and all
that stuff so i i can't wait for more
i can't wait for you guys to see it i
can't wait to hear what everyone
talks about because uh this it's it's
it's literally
what you want but it because it's like
it takes its time and lets you relish in
some things and
has such a great sense of awe and wonder
uh
yeah and it's dark too you know it's
very good
it's good yeah it's good it's good it's
freaking it's great
can't wait for you guys to watch it yeah
and i can't wait to share a reaction
with you guys because
yeah this one's different this one's
different best pilot like you said thank
you
best pilot out of the three marvel shows
this year it's the best pilot of them
all
can't say the best show yet but the
pilot oh yeah